now leaders from the african union and
the european union are meeting for the
second day of a summit in brussels
african leaders are using the event to
repeat their demands for waivers of
covid19 vaccine patients the eu has
responded by saying it will invest in
new factories in africa to produce the
vaccines locally the summit's being
billed as a reset in relations between
the regional blocks further
announcements of funding are expected
today dw correspondent jack parrack is
in brussels and i asked him if there's
been any progress between au and eu and
the eu over more equal access to covid19
vaccines
at the moment we don't think so we know
that this is really the big battle
between the leaders of the african union
there's 40 of them here and the 27
european leaders the the the south
african president cyril ramaphosa has
called this vaccine apartheid regularly
and accused the europeans of preventing
the the possibility of african people
getting the vaccines that they need to
get through the pandemic under 10 of
africa african citizens
are fully vaccinated with two doses many
countries in the european union are
hitting 70 of booster doses already but
the europeans simply say that
releasing the trips waiver so allowing
intellectual property rights to be
completely suspended so that everybody
could make these mrna vaccines wherever
they like but that simply doesn't work
they say that there needs to be the
know-how there needs to be the
technological understanding of how to
create these vaccines and that's why
they say it's better to uh to to for
them to create factories and and then
and then sell them into africa uh as i
say this is the big battle at the summit
but there have been other issues that
have been going on yesterday france said
it was pulling out of mali removing
just under 2500 troops into other parts
of the sahel region of africa and that's
been a big big issue the security issue
that the leaders have been talking about
as well
while those leaders from africa and
europe debate covid19 vaccine supply a
pharmaceutical company has unveiled
plans for new scaled-down vaccine
factories
germany's biontech says its so-called
bion containers by ontamers could
provide millions of doses of its
coronavirus vaccine in african countries
other diseases could also be targeted
these containers could help advance the
global fight against covet 19.
tiny vaccine factories model units
developed by german pharma firm biontec
to produce mrna vaccines you can build
it on stock for example and you can
deploy it very quickly and you scale it
to any size you want and then it became
very clear
that this is the perfect case actually
for africa
at the moment only about 12 percent of
the african population has received two
vaccine shots
by on taxes its by-ontainers could
initially produce up to 50 million doses
per year making africa less dependent on
imports
at the same time the company's ceo uber
shaheen made it clear biontech won't
suspend its vaccine patent
but he also said the company won't
challenge vaccine copying in africa
we recognize that that vaccine vaccine
equity is not given
at the moment we had a wonderful meeting
with our partners from africa and and
one of the most impressive statements
was was that vaccine equity is not about
the past
it's about the future
welcomed some african leaders on
wednesday at the company's production
site in marburg to present the new
project
while some criticize biontech's
initiative saying the european build
solution is not local enough senegalese
president mackey cell says it's historic
this day finally puts an end to vaccine
injustice during a pandemic that has
affected the world
we have experienced that the african
continent was left alone because africa
only produces around one percent of the
vaccines that are administered on the
continent
in the future biontech also wants to use
the bioentaners to produce vaccines
against malaria or tuberculosis the
first prototypes will be implemented in
rwanda senegal or south africa by the
end of this year